so leute und herzlich willkommen zurück
zu einer weiteren folge minecraft exit
auf dem server kev meint ja das brauch
ich gleich kommen
da bttv gleich kommen sollen
lassen die mal angreifen dann nehme ich
noch eine folge eben auf borowski ich
weiß nicht ob skype gehen kann war seine
folge hat schon seit zehn minuten
wahrscheinlich im gange ist das ist dann
halt ein bisschen kacke
also ich rufe den jetzt mal an einfach
und da bietet tv gleichkommen mit ist
dann krieg geben so scheiße ich hoffe
ich geht das jetzt alles hin
nebenbei ohne dass ihr hier irgendwie
was davon hier die stars anna lotta ton
so ich habe in der letzten folge gesagt
dass ich hallo hallo wie lang ist eine
folge schon kräftig wem du streams
gedacht ob es leben auf
milli vanilli war ich nehme aber gerade
so schnell also bei mir kommt die folge
was wir gerade aufnehmen
nicht übermorgen sondern danach der tag
also kein problem
jetzt macht auch spaß gut nur dass die
leute sich dann die jetzt eventuell
graffiti im stream sind und mich
eventuell auch gucken sich beschweren
aber hallo an alle leute die aus dem
stream
ich wollte eigentlich nur zwei folgen
aufnehmen aber dann dachte ich mir
sorgen wenn die gleich kommen ja das
grüne dem ich gleich gesagt wir das ist
ziemlich wahrscheinlich dass die stream
und ich mache mich gerade schon kriegs
fertig das heißt ich habe genau das in
kripp dass ich wieso schon für den krieg
brauche ach so und du brauchst mir keine
elektrik stabs geben okay ich habe
gesehen dass ich doch noch zwei electric
resistenzen hatte deswegen passt das und
mir wurde tipps gegeben dass diese sich
anpasst blöcke gar nicht so teuer sind
du kannst einfach acht mal die gleiche
farbe nehmen also acht mal zwölf brot ja
ich weiß das habe ich auch schon mal das
wusste ich mich deswegen ja ja ja ja
nicht schlimm ich glaube ich hätte es
doch nicht so machen dass ein bisschen
kaka aus froh dass ich dachte jetzt
gerade dass das vielleicht ein bisschen
blöd wenn du aufgenommen hättest weil
das halt so dass ich dann irgendwie weiß
ich wer dann etwa 20 minuten western
schon bei 10 und so dass wir ein
bisschen kacke aber wenn du stream zeit
alles perfekt ja gut so ich baue was
machst du gerade
ich habe ein bisschen strip club
gearbeitet und werde jetzt wie gesagt
habe alles rausgeholt was ich zum
kämpfen brauche ich weiß gar nicht ich
will nicht ich weiß ich aus welchem
material ich meinen dings machen soll
den boden meines hauses ich habe ihnen
die bock auf schnee hast du die neuen
regeln gelesen
ja ja eigentlich schon also wie jetzt
bei facebook also op äpfel sind verboten
regenerationstraining also op äpfel sind
verboten
normale goldene äpfel nicht das ist ein
großer unterschied
ich weiß nicht also das ist aber auch um
finden das ist das dann nicht wieder
also normaler himmel die sind nicht so
also die regenerieren dich nur etwas
schneller so sagt man sozusagen nicht so
viel hunger verlierst weißt du das war
es auch schon
ja gut dann was es noch verboten man
darf sich nicht in andere häuser reihen
porten genau das heißt das kann ich eben
machen und zwar weil ich meine portale
umsetzen weil ich habe alle meine
portale direkt in der stadt immer
gemacht hast du die spiegel aber ist ja
super verfeindeten städten so aber
sicherheitshalber wirklich natürlich ist
die ganzen spiegel einfach mal die ich
in denen ich in stadt roth habe
beispielsweise setze ich dann ein
bisschen außerhalb von stadtroda auf dem
baum drauf den habe ich sogar schon auf
dem bau ist natürlich neues was da auch
immer noch schön einen knicks
nee mach ich nicht mehr weißt du auch
warum weißt du warum die königin
ich halte ich hab ihn warte
läuft alles so ja aber im privat- und
diamant und spitzhacke weißt du warum
ich muss den spielraum hinsetzen ich
habe mit kilos abgenommen die magische
miesmuschel essen nur gegen mich nur
wieso sie hat quasi gar nicht zu
verstehen
ethos hat gefragt magische miesmuschel
darf ich neben kraft das haus einen
riesigen penis setzen
und ich habe mich erst gegen diese frage
geweigert weil ich nicht wollte dass in
unserer stadt ein penis steht das ist
eine ganz normale frage die königin darf
entscheiden
königin sagt unbedingt ganz normale
frage aus dem alltäglichen leben darf
ich dir dein haus einen riesigen nur
wenige stellen wer hat noch nicht an so
wahrscheinlich habe es wo es geht bei
uns wo ist denn das größte weidegebiet
du kannst mir das sagen beide bohrer
weiß ich gar nicht
und dann käme dann kann er das heftigste
ich frage die königin liebst du mich sie
sagt nein was alles königin dass es kann
nicht sein was da passiert ist
das sind wir echt hier ein bisschen
überzogen zu sein bin ich hier wird das
finde ich auch nicht mehr gut hören dass
man hin oder her
also ich hab ja kilian gefragt türen
darf man auf machen deswegen jetzt
keiner beschweren wenn ich jetzt in
statt gelb eine tür aufgemacht habe ja
klar türen davon immer auf man deswegen
du darfst dich an deinem haus ja selber
porten auch die spiegel kommen jetzt
wieder hier rein so ich muss irgendwohin
wo es schweine gibt es ein steiniger tür
gehängt wochen futter farben haben weil
alle beschweren sich mal alle kräfte
macht jetzt ein bordell da fertig und
die puppenmutter vergisst die heimischen
pflichten
wenn ich nein das stimmt gar nicht
sollte schnell lernen lieber mal was
hier für uns hier machen ich suche ja
schweine die ganze dabei ist kommen so
wenige schweine mussten auch schweine
ich muss noch 53 schweine töten und die
spawn hier einfach nicht das ist das
komische eigentlich müsste noch schweine
auf der weide oder nicht also ganz klar
auf gras ich werde angerufen aber ich
gehe nicht dran an schweine
wir haben allgemein so wenig mobbing wie
bei uns ne ich finde das richtig richtig
komisch irgendwie dafür wurde aber auch
gesagt ich kann das mit kühlen machen
weil es stakes kommt aufs gleiche raus
mit kühen
nun steht er sicher naja farc und ich
habe natürlich genau dann meinen zweiten
sehen steinig dabei ja mach ich denn
jetzt meinen boden was aushandeln die
anderen ihren boden gemacht wolltest du
nicht schnee nehmen ja aber es muss ein
bisschen zur stadt passen die anderen
alle normales mitgenommen dann nehme ich
auch noch mal das wort und butt butt
butt butt butt
aber ich hätte acht ein hase ja ich hab
verschiedenen tötete das war sache
bekommt aber irgendwie hätte ich auch
mehr bock auf dieses dschungel holz was
ich schon mal verwendet hat und wohin
alles in den mülleimer geschmissen hat
durch ungünstig würde ich viel geben zu
hinten zu den bäumen fand ich das hat
oder wann die dahin sollte dann
eigentlich für mich auch nicht so schwer
sein die ganzen schweinen zu fahren weil
ich habe ja ein schwert mit after life
in das heißt die chance ist auch da dass
die us truppen sozusagen in der gruppe
haben vielleicht eine hand voll rein und
dann geht das so hin und her bis sich
dann vielleicht so richtig viele habe
aber richtig pech mit das bahnrad hab
ich das gefühl richtig pech i hab gerade
vergessen dass wir den timber immer
drauf haben und der ganze baum umfällt
becker ist übelst den riesenkonzern
erhalte ich gerade das
mega heftig electric nach war schön aber
wir haben es nicht einfach die mordfälle
an gemacht und habe nichts gemacht und
dann dachten wir sofort alle anderen am
ersten die ganzen fünf minuten box
getötet aber naja wenigstens ist bei uns
nicht so heftig wie ein staat droht
dieses hoffe die jungs brauchen auch
abgerissen jemand altes das muss auch
noch diese folge machen
du bist daheim nämlich richtig an ja
kannst du dich gleich so bald direkt die
sonne untergegangen ist ins bett legen
ich logge dich schnell aus weil wenn ich
hier bin in japan verbinden
der kölner schweine spawn glaube ich nur
tat richtig oder schweinebauch er jede
generell durch marius seinem bett liegt
ja ich weiß ich kann nicht schon ins
bett ich glaub ich nicht im bett und
nacht doch ich kann es batman mit kann
front gehen
jo 321 kanzleramt eine schweinefarm
lohnt sich mich ich will das kann ich ja
doof ich will nämlich die zuschauer an
sich ist keine normale schweinefarm wenn
ich mich ein schwein eschborner habe
beim start der gamescom zwei weil da ich
lava und wir haben direkt fertige steaks
zum verzehr und das nonstop das ist das
was wir brauchen ist scheiße schaffst du
es denn brocken fans alleine zu
klatschen
wieso ja weil ich jetzt hat der
neureiche event jetzt höchstens noch ein
und danach noch eine folge aufnehmen
also höchstens die und danach noch eine
die jungs 19 uhr anfangen ich könnte
noch richtung haben
ich weiß nicht ob die einrichtung haben
weil ich habe einfach gerade mal so
interessen cyber in der aufnahme von
denen geguckt da hatten die sogar nur
die hälfte der sachen in voller rüstung
ja aber wie gesagt haben ich alles an
ihr glaube ich ja ich hab jetzt also die
scale aber will ich halt einem kampf
verwenden und ich habe die skater in der
letzten folge komplett alles hat sollte
alles hat an breaking alles hat
protection 4
also die heftigste nutzt und sachen die
es gibt dann hab ich jetzt auch noch
geil wäre was du drauf machen kannst was
das ganze noch verbessert ist feierlich
oder was das sobald sich jemand schlägt
brennt er das ist was noch geht ich habe
drauf vitali
reich ist aber jetzt noch drauf das
binnen-i vitali vier habe ich darauf
also vitalität 4
wie berichtet kluge wenn dich jemand
schlägt besteht die chance dass die
stadt herzen essen verlierst das heißt
auch übels geil eigentlich peter die
vier oha das sind geile sachen und ich
hab halt noch 12 geheimtipps ich habe
als auch in frost bogen mit dem man halt
langsam wird dann werde ich glaube ich
auch ein entfernung erstmal den frust
bau verwenden weil auch wenn man fliegt
dass man mit dem frost bei langsamer das
habe ich mit cross ausprobiert das ist
wirklich gut
das ja ich hab noch ganz sicher hilft
uns aber stabil und er ist ja nicht
erschwert die uns nicht gesperrt worden
habe ich mich auch deswegen denke ich
wahrscheinlich werde ein erst mit dem
frost abschießen im kampf dann in
vergiftung zauberstab und dann einfach
drauf klatsch mit dem ende ins wort das
sind ganz gute taktik man gratis pony
gar kein schwein jahren einen kleinen
lauf dass so viele schweine habe ich
hier ein und zwar über 40 schweine bis
ich dann aber danach ist die farm denke
ich mal auch relativ zügig fertig ich
habe hier noch starr pieces das heißt
ich hab doch eigentlich auch noch starb
es ist irgendwo drin oder hast du
eigentlich unseren professor iks unser
professor experiment von mir und sommer
em mitbekommen was habt ihr gemacht wo
wir versucht haben dass wir ein spanner
für goldene chocobos machen hat aber
leider nicht geklappt wie wir es
hinkriegen page ja so wie ich das mit
mir so wie ich die anderen sportler
hersteller sich dann nonstop goldene
turbo boost töte und wir haben zwar mit
einem getestet und wer hat nicht
geklappt also wohl nicht mal ende wurde
man kann das als goldenes schon gross
fordert deswegen klappt das leider nicht
das egal gewesen stell dir das vor
nein spanner denn nur goldene tor und
ich habe ja einen baum gerade die sind
im bad mit diesem thema dingsbums
gemacht ja meine halbe fredericks ist
kaputt
da musst du aufpassen und eine freitext
richtig geil ich werde jetzt reparieren
so
jetzt erstmal alle verzauberungen wieder
runter ich muss ja irgendwo uns weiß
gebiet ihre ein deswegen glaube ich auch
jetzt hierhin ihr müsst noch irgendwo
schweine seien kommt manfred raith sache
nicht reparieren man das blöd na gut ist
egal heute noch eure hilfe wo finde ich
schweine
ich habe meinen links gar nicht dabei
ich habe auch gar keinen fall dabei ich
pizza so ich benötige
was ist das haupt material noch mal in
unserer stadt babbel ich habe wirklich
und after life drauf wie bitte ich hab
was ist der unterschied zwischen marble
cobblestone hatte ich habe ist sowie
queenston und marvel comics wie kabel
soll ja ich nehme aber marble also wir
haben marble queenston glaube ich neben
für die wand marvel kabels daun
dabei war das mache das dach meines
hauses da habe ich klinsmann genommen
relativ gleich aus aber ich habe jetzt
einfach mehr mabel queenston deswegen
möchte ich meine tipps haben
was ist ein player bio
darunter so groß ist denn so ganz wenige
höhe ich glaube planes ist es nicht so
treppe oder nicht es nicht um mich
behindert
wann ist
planes sumpf sohn bist du dienste aus
was kann man sich am leichtesten farbe
machen knochen eier knochen stimmt würde
hier da mal so sagen ansonsten pflanzen
alles mögliche ich glaube ich mache mir
meine ich mache keine tür sondern ich
mache quasi abitur abitur direkt durch
die tür
ich werde mir dings machen dass mit
diesem magic blog meister heraus blog
einfach keine türen aber wie willst das
war mit dem magic blog wird da nichts
marble ach so ja doch dort überall sind
magic blog durchgehend kannst ja aber
der ist doch hell
na ja stimme ist so und ich mir auch
gesagt weswegen der hell ist und zwar
liegt das an custom kallas was man durch
ob die fein an hat und bei mir am shader
ich brauche noch mehr mabel irgendwie
hab ich ein glück ich noch schweine kann
ich mal finden außer in der wüste aber
irgendwie sehe ich keine sollen das kann
ich mal einfach verbrennen dass das zu
babbel com aber der aufwand eigentlich
zu groß am menschlichsten wenn du mit
saic touch die abbaus habe ich hab gar
keine höhle zu suchen und die stars dann
doch dann kannte liga zwar mit kohle
wegschmelzen packe ich lieber ein
bisschen holz da rein und so kaum show
und papa brauchen nur schweine sind 40
schweine wirklich zu viel verlangt
und erst mal alles auf einem fleck das
eher geil sowie kommt da noch rein und
da wieder ein bisschen babbel darf macht
dann die wende
ich weiß nicht solch große glas dings
nehmen oder scheiben haben wir schreiben
den scheiben genommen ok baumscheiben
genommen dann nämlich schreiben die
frage ist jetzt natürlich gibt es eine
bestimmte spawn rate
das heißt wenn manche titel da sind es
bald keine anderen mehr sind hier auf
der weide nur schafe rumlaufen will ich
alle schafe kühe werden danach spawn
plätze frei und schweine kommen oder wie
kann das sein
ja eigentlich eigentlich nützt es so
sein wenn man logisch argumentiert wenn
dann töte ich jetzt mal alles weg alter
ein grünes schoko ihr grünes in der
wildnis ja das tue ich jetzt 3 ich bin
nur schweine da war einst wie du kann
braucht essen letzten ausgabe werde ich
übrigens jetzt gerade bin ich dabei zu
bauen also halbwegs kommt er mein haus
mit 1 des trainers gut also dieser
erstens küche weil dies glaube ich sehr
wichtig dann kann ich ja wenn du magst
kann ich dann diese falle sozusagen
dabei die rocco im keller einbauen
welche falle meinst du ja da diese
automatische fleischproduktion
ach so ja stimmt das kannst du mir die
essenausgabe hast dann wäre das so gut
bei dir denke ich nur na klar das kann
man machen kann man ja so ich weiß gar
nicht was ist hier überhaupt irgendeine
technik drauf nehme allerdings weiß ich
ob er wenigstens noch nicht oder fragt
die heute gibt es das ich habe keine
dass wenigstens schon mal automatisch in
der kiste einfallen lassen dann geht's
nicht verloren muss man da nicht immer
gestehen ich bin auch so mächtig hat
direkt neben dem hopper also ich glaube
hier gibt's keine ratten hamster jetzt
mal kommen und verarscht brockens 20 uhr
wird jetzt gesagt ich glaube dass ich
glaube das nicht ganz
verrückt ich muss gleich in eine folge
kurz beenden
so hat ich muss hier hatte ich brauch
sticks habe ich noch 6 da hab ich doch
sticks bestimmte steuern johannes dieses
pony keine schweine ich suche wirklich
macht das wäre zum beispiel so eine
aufgabe ich denke für eine youtube folge
wäre das nichts ich würde echt keinen
bock 15 minuten ruhm zu laufen und dann
nur noch schwein zu suchen
dann stimmt da hast du recht jetzt schon
wieder dunkel sponsor erst recht nicht
spox hühner kakina ich mag nicht wenn
ich hätte mir jeden scheiß nehmen können
es hat mich für schweine entschieden
dann kommen wir keine schweine ganz
aktuell so viel bühler so viele kühe
wer das porto schon lange fertig jetzt
war 3 hoch bis zu dumpfe dieser welt
alle sagen da war ein schwein ich bin
doch nicht blind oder oder vielleicht
bisschen jedenfalls
schaaf ich werde nachher gucken wie ich
das ganze hier abtrennen werde meine
lieben freunde nicht dass jetzt
irgendwer beschwert
das ist ja alles klar komm schon
ja noch sie einfach an ja genau wo seid
ihr ich frag mal unsere königin ob sie
die antwort mag ich fragte jetzt mal ob
ich der ich heute schweine finden werde
wenn wenn ich du wäre ob ich weine
finden werden die frage welche richtung
ist suchen muss soll ich im norden
suchen
kummer du kriegst positive antworten
alte sollte hat sie gesagt da das ist
das klingt spitze also im soll im norden
suchen ja meine fall jetzt vorbei ich
habe letzte folge schon ganz klein
bisschen aus versehen überzogen
deswegen werde ich die folge jetzt
einfach mal schon beenden ich würde
sagen es euch gefallen hat könnt ihr die
bewertungen lassen schreibt mir
weiterhin in die kommentare aus welchen
materialien ich eventuell ein haus bauen
soll
kev macht sein leistung weiter und ich
werde jetzt noch eine folge auf einem in
der hoffnung dass brocken fenster kommen
werden